لقد قاموا بالفعل باستخراج المناهج في الميناء
تم تعدين أوكرانيا عدة مرات بالفعل
قال لجميع زملائنا اسمحوا لهم
أنا أقوم بإزالة الألغام ، من فضلك لا تدع السفن تدخل
مع دخول الحبوب المسلحة بالحبوب
[موسيقى]
في الصباح
إنها خدعة
حسنًا ، أولاً ، هناك بعض الموضوعية
أشياء سأقولها الآن للعالم
تنتج سنويا ما يقرب من 8800
مليون طن من حبوب القمح 800 لكن
يقال لنا الآن أن أوكرانيا
التي ستصدر 20 مليون طن
[موسيقى]
إعطاء الفرصة ل
بحر آزوف
الرقص
سوف تسقط
على استعداد لتوفير تصدير خالية من المتاعب و
بما في ذلك حول قائمة انتظار الحفارات
يذهب
[موسيقى]
و
أخيرًا أسهل شيء هو أن تحصل عليه
إقليم روسيا البيضاء معظم التنورة
رخيصة لأنه على واحد حتى الولادة
ميناء البلطيق
بحر البلطيق وما وراءه إلى أي نقطة
لكن من أجل هذا تحتاج إلى رفع عقوبات الاتحاد الأوروبي
بيلاروسيا
[موسيقى]
مكبر الصوت الخلفي حفرة عالية
قلب القلب
حسنًا ، نعم استنزاف سيدة NGK ولنا أسيو
الحمض النووي
الخام لفيروس نقص المناعة البشرية
تشتهر دمية تانر بذلك